good Kev so you're uh you're born in the
Philippines but you're kind of from
Vegas is that what I gather yeah yeah I
used I used to live in Vegas so that's
crazy like where uh off of Craig and the
15. that's wow it's like the north side
uh North where'd you go to high school
out out there
um High School way did you go to high
school in Vegas oh no uh in the
Philippines okay so when did you move
like what point of time in your life
were you like I'm going to pick up and
move to Vegas uh it wasn't necessarily
like my decision to like a family
related thing but um so it was around
like I would say a 16. okay 17. runtime
like right when I dropped out of like
soft food not sophomore like the second
Sim of my college okay yeah like right
when I dropped out like my papers was
processed for like uh so probably 17
yeah I was 17 when I came so you get to
Vegas and then it's melting hot and
you're like why do we move here man I
have a funny story about that actually
So I entered through Seattle okay I
stayed there for a week because my
family was there like on my grandma's
side and then uh finally got with my
immediate family like my mom's sisters
and everybody in L.A so we was out here
for a year
and prices just got a little too
expensive and that's why you went to
Vegas prices are still getting a little
too expensive
and I feel like Vegas getting hit with
that too it is for sure it's definitely
I mean now you guys got the Raiders
there's like a basketball prize on the
way the Clippers too somebody's coming
yeah I don't know if it's gonna be a
Clipper somebody's coming
did you perform at a Clippers game yes
sir that got to be cool yeah are you a
basketball fan
um I wouldn't say like through and
through I am but definitely admire the
sport respectively right yeah it was
Filipino night
yeah Filipino Heritage night when you go
to the Filipino Heritage night
um have you ever ran into a
little tiny fat round man named Brian
Sampson no I'm good all right just gonna
make sure I'm sure Ross gonna introduce
you to him he's like everyone's like
Filipino uncle in the music industry oh
yeah he's just stay away he gets you in
trouble he'll get you in trouble all
right okay
um how long have you been like actually
like really taking the music profession
serious like
um it was
right when I dropped out to in the
Philippines like right at that
transition like um right when I dropped
out I started making metal music like
full time
and then basically like I would say like
in the to the world's eyes where they
would say I took it seriously it's like
when I got to the states and started
trying to rap to sing so you're doing
like metal yeah like [__] like give
me like a comparison to the death core
technical death core technical death
metal brutal death core the whole death
Spectrum Jesus so would that be like
Slayer type [__] the um because I know
there's a bunch of sub genres yes
there's like industrial they're actually
right on the money because Slater Slayer
if it wasn't for them death battle
wouldn't exist right they're kind of
like the Run DMC of death metal
thrash metal they're thrashed yeah yeah
I don't even know so what's what's the
biggest death metal band
I would say dying fetus I heard a dying
fetus yeah they Cannibal Corpse Cannibal
Corpse yeah damn that [__] is have you
ever heard of uh
is it job for a cowboy Oh Yeah now
they're legendary death core death metal
people still like you know debate about
this yo listen I was driving uh me and
my boy TK who's a producer of mine who
works for me and he we were driving from
Phoenix to LA in the middle of the night
he had to stay awake
and I was supposed to take a nap
so we swapped seats and he throws on
yeah drop for is it drop her account for
a cowboy yeah
that's the kind of [__] you were making
oh my God is crazy
yo I literally was like bro what the
[__] is going on right now like what is
even going on right now so you were
doing like that
wow yep [__] salute full time so you
were like you've been in a lot of uh
like [__] mosh pits yeah
unfortunately
mosh pits are um
they're fun I just saw I mean I just saw
Metallica the other day and and
obviously they're kind of like not death
metal they're quite the opposite
but there was tons of pits still going
on throughout the whole like floor and I
was like oh this reminds me of high
school right yeah but I'm sure the pizza
it goes Death Metal Show are a little
bit more aggressive it's crazy it's like
there's a whole lot of like mental
stress that actually goes on with like
actually even the artist that goes into
it because it takes a different kind of
like a set of group who would want to
see like you know the violence ensue
right in front of their eyes yeah
because it's like that's actually what
happens when even the guitar just starts
like damn are you a [__] right
everybody start smiling oh my God so is
there a big scene for that in the
Philippines
pretty small pretty very very small
that's why when I started like kind of
grinding for it like I had to kind of
put like this layer on my figure like
how to approach the fan base because
because it would just be like
white boys like from here SoCal and in
Norway sometimes yeah yeah yeah there I
think there's a uh it correct me if I'm
wrong wasn't there a death metal band
that one of the members killed one of
the other members in Adam
um I don't know about or is that was
that or was that like a
they probably don't tell they use the uh
album art for they were talking about
yeah Mayhem I don't know uh that's a
black metal actually black metal yeah
black metal that is that from Norway
yeah yes and there's a big band that's
uh what's the big band that's [__]
yeah I think it was Mayhem Mayhem the
band Mayhem they use the uh his
bandmate's body took a picture of it in
his album art
yeah that's hardcore for real yeah I see
why you're into it man